وكانت سلمى عبد العزيز تتابع
التطورات في أوكرانيا وهي تنضم إلينا
الآن من لندن، لذا فلنبدأ سلمى
بهذا الهجوم على مقر أسطول البحر الأسود
الذي يمكن أن يكون
تطورًا مهمًا ولكن التفاصيل المؤكدة
لا تزال نادرة، فما الذي نتعلمه أكثر من ذلك،
لذلك هذا  تلقينا صباح اليوم بيانًا من
القوات الخاصة الأوكرانية يتضمن مزيدًا من
الادعاءات بشأن هذا الهجوم الذي وقع بالفعل في
قلب شبه جزيرة القرم التي تحتلها روسيا، وهو
المقر الرئيسي للأسطول البحري التابع لها.
وقالت القوات الخاصة الأوكرانية في هذا
البيان إن هناك عشرات من
القتلى والجرحى من القوات الروسية  وفي
هذا الهجوم، قال أيضًا إن توقيت
الهجوم كان مهمًا على ما يبدو، حيث
حدث خلال اجتماع رفيع المستوى ظهر
أمس، ومضى البيان
ليقول إن ذلك أدى إلى وجود كبار
أعضاء قيادة
الأسطول البحري من بين القتلى
والجرحى.  الآن لم تقدم أوكرانيا أي
دليل يدعم هذه الادعاءات وروسيا
تعارضها، وأعتقد كما
ذكرتم كيم، أن آخر بيان
لدينا من المسؤولين الروس هو أن
جنديًا واحدًا لا يفتقد أي شيء أكثر من
ذلك بالطبع، فهم يعترفون بأنهم يقرون
بذلك  تم ضرب المقر الرئيسي
كما رأيتم في
مقاطع الفيديو الدرامية تلك هناك، بغض النظر عن
العواقب الدقيقة والطبيعة الدقيقة
لهذا الهجوم ونتيجته. وقد
أوضحت أوكرانيا في الأسابيع الأخيرة أن أي
هدف روسي في عمق
المناطق التي تحتلها روسيا هو في متناول اليد.  لقد
سمعت هناك من
صدفة ماثيو عدة ضربات على عدة مناطق
من السفن إلى مراكز القيادة إلى الآن
المقر الرئيسي مرة أخرى في المناطق المحتلة من قبل روسيا،
مما يعطي إحساسًا بأن
الكرملين أصبح أكثر عرضة للخطر بعيدًا عن
تلك الخطوط الأمامية.